the second round of the US Open Golf
Championship underway right now behind
me you can see all of the action this
weekend on the Fox broadcast network you
wanted me now to talk a little bit about
golf and the future of golf is the
United States Golf Association chief
executive officer Mike Davis Mike thank
you very much for being here great
special guest with us we do this is the
trophy that would be the trophy that's
been around since 1895 it's fantastic to
hear the cheers coming from the golf
course you know everybody's trying to
make the cut right now this has been an
interesting two days weather-wise the
challenge this is a tough place it has
me first of all Brett you're at one of
the greatest golf courses in the United
States for that matter the world it was
one of the five founding clubs of the
USGA and it truly is a great test of
golf but it was a tale of two really two
days yesterday some of the highest wins
we've ever had at a US Open and players
were just hanging on yet today really
good scoring four conditions very light
wind and some soft conditions and they
can go low when that happens so did you
feel like you had to set it up a little
tougher because last year was 16 under
you didn't want to get to 16 under this
year well you know in so many cases
Mother Nature has a big seat at the
table and last year she was very calm to
the players but but she's doing a few
different things this year and I think
you know we really in some ways you try
to set this golf course up and any US
Open Golf Course so you're testing every
element of the players skill so it's a
shot making abilities their course
management skills even their ability to
handle their nerves so but Shinnecock
kills absolutely can hold its own this
is a great golf course and a great test
of golf what do you say about the future
of golf as a game and where where it's
going so Brett you know very healthy
game we have more junior golfers in the
United States than ever more girls
playing more women playing more
non-caucasians playing so in a sense in
the game is growing globally and it
Brett it's a game of a lifetime it
it's a game really like other sports
where players of differing ability can
play on an echo bait equitable basis
through the handicap system but at the
same time you know golf has its
challenges I mean one of the things off
has to you know continues to focus on is
how long it takes to play the game the
cost of the game and then there's even
some long-term issues of you know water
continues to be an issue for the game
and it will be a bigger issue in the
decades to come and it's frankly one of
the things that the usj really does
tackle it it's about the long-term
health and enjoyment of the game for all
those who play it for somebody who
doesn't watch golf religiously why
should they watch this weekend
listen this is our nation's national
championship the oldest championship in
this country have been around since 1895
and you know it's it's unique about this
week is truly unique in the sense that
this this really is the ultimate test of
golf this is unlike other weeks of the
year where we're testing every element
of their shot making skill and you know
for well over a century you know these
golfers or golfers know that the US Open
tough testing off but at the end of the
day what we're gonna hand us trophy out
right here and in the Jack Nicklaus gold
medal to to the low 72 hole score and I
can promise you it's going to be
somebody that his is his worked their
way around this golf course and and done
a great job in terms of thinking
thinking their way right now Dustin
Johnson's leading and obviously he hits
it a mile is that a challenge for you
setting up courses that you've got these
guys that are hitting it just gargantuan
distances and it's it's changing the
game you know it is the game is the
game's evolved its innovated itself
Brett when we played this championship
well over a hundred years ago in 1896
the course was only 44 hundred yards now
it's about 70 400 yards and you know
courses have had to expand over those
periods of time but you know distance is
only one element of the test it's you
know it's it's your ability to
be accurate with the ball distance
control your ability to when you get
into trouble recover and i'll all
tomorrow off course here's another
difference I think we have this graphic
of the payout for the winner who
eventually gets this trophy back in 1896
that winner got a few bucks basically
$150 see Raymond Floyd 115 thousand goes
up to one point one and then first place
this year two point one second place
gets more than the 2004 winner retreat
Retief Goosen yeah I wonder when James
phallus was playing I wonder if you you
looked at that and from an inflationary
somehow I don't think $150 would it
would equal what the winners gonna make
this week all right Mike we appreciate
it thanks for having us Brett it's gonna
be Fareed great being with you thanks